est ce que vous croyez aux ovnis oui et
je voudrais en voir les autres lui un
sujet qui fascine depuis toujours l'un
des premiers témoignages à la télé
c'était en 1960
cet agriculteur du nord de la france en
est persuadé il a bien aperçu une
soucoupe volante sur le bord de la route
rouge qui arrivait sur new d'arriver sur
la droite et dans un virage de
développer la route et d'adp est parti
sur la gauche
alors on a dû freiner brusquement pour
l'éviter parce qu'on prépare pas sa
place douze ans plus tard en 1972
nouveaux cas inexpliqués d'ovni au
volant de sa voiture patrick s'est lui
aussi retrouvé nez à nez avec une
soucoupe volante
l'engin de 7 mètres de long 10 de
hauteur était totalement silencieux
militaire
en forme de demi bol bien plus gros
qu'un arbre sur un pied d'un mètre de
diamètre à peu près et d'apparence
métallique de tap l'aluminium autres
témoignages marquants celui de ce couple
dans le puy-de-dôme en 1980 ils n'ont
pas seulement vu des aliens ils leur ont
aussi parlé des extraterrestres vêtu de
sombre d'une taille d'un mètre soixante
dix au visage imberbe et qui seraient
infiltrés parmi nous ils prétendent par
exemple être introduit dans toutes nos
usines dans tous nos terrains militaires
et tout ce que vous voulez y prétendre
de nous surveiller pouvoir arrêter notre
action est paralysé la production tout
ce que l'on veut
à l'échelon mondial partout en france
les rencontres du troisième type
s'enchaînent 1994 le ciel des alpes
maritimes et le théâtre de phénomènes
paranormaux
les habitants auraient vu voler
plusieurs objets au dessus du village
des idoles
grand rentrée dessous je pense à un
avion qui passait au bercail ça
disparaît c'est le bleu de ses lumières
est un but que nous n'avons pas sur la
terre à partir des années 2000 les
témoignages à la télé se font plus rares
mais les ovnis continue d'alimenter
parfois les journaux télévisés en 2014
des points lumineux sont aperçues dans
le ciel
ovni ou non écoutez la réaction de cette
femme prise en direct dans une vidéo
amateur et les sétois maison se voit des
étoiles
mais il faut surtout il faut afficher
pas quoi là tous ces cas sont recensés
étudié par le geipan le groupe d'études
et d'informations sur les phénomènes
aérospatiaux non identifiés geipan
l'appareil chaque année il reçoit 1000
signalement en moyenne
[Musique]